for the first time in Bachelorette
history we're gonna have two
bachelorettes that's right it is going
to be Britt and Kaitlyn
Wow that's a first
hey guys I'm Sarah Flanagan and this
Bachelorette twist is trending on easy
now the 25 men on night one who are
going to have the ultimate say about who
they think would make the best wife
so if fighting for one guy's attention
wasn't enough these two will have to
battle it out again for the hearts of 25
guys what's going on in your head right
now I'd say we would make a pretty good
first impression with the tears and the
laughs yeah what about you I mean I'm
super grateful I think it's an amazing
opportunity it's I don't know I mean
it's more than I can comprehend wow
these two left for love
The Bachelor will be trying to find his
dance shoes instead of moving darlington
we're gonna be moving to LA for for a
couple weeks at least to be on Dancing
with the Stars
congratulations we may have guessed that
American yes I'm the worst best secret
let's go back to the new bachelorette
who do you think the guys will choose
Britt or Kaitlyn send me your thoughts
on Twitter and use that hashtag et now
bye guys
you